do you see any resolution to this
because all I'm seeing is escalation
escalation obviously the winter is going
to stop a lot of the fighting but Putin
is kind of posturing like he might
launch another Invasion from the north
of Belarus right now all I see is
escalations do you see any way that this
could possibly de-escalate I know Putin
said he's open to negotiations during
the upcoming G20 meeting do you think
that's going to be successful I viewed a
Russian broadcast last night that was
talking about how there's going to be no
operations this winter I think there
probably will be but it'll be minor I
see no off ramp this year yeah what do
you think an off-ramp would look like a
negotiated piece but it's going to have
to be the United States this is a hard
thing to say do you tell Ukraine to give
up you know Ukrainian territory you know
what the sad thing is and well is it sad
1994 the Bucharest treaty remember that
that Ukraine was like the third largest
nuclear power in the world at the time
that's right and and the United States
Russia and Great Britain Province the
defender borders if they'd give up the
nukes and they gave up the nukes and
who's defending their borders